- SpongeBob is talking a
lot about global warming,
and he's only looking at
it from one point of view.
- Why I hate the news.
- Brainwashed by the mainstream media.
- Oh, brainwashed.
- Santa just is white.
- Jesus was a white man too.
- He wrote a sentence ending
with a brand new word.
- [Sean] The President and
a small group of people
know exactly what he meant.
- It seems like a weird
title for me to use
because I'm a journalist.
At least that's what I think I am.
I worked at a journalistic institution.
I just did a piece at
"The New York Times."
Can you call me a journalist?
I'm a journalist, right?
Now I'm feeling insecure.
Okay, so whatever.
I'm a journalist but I
kind of hate the news.
Let me explain.
(whooshing)
- [Announcer] CNN Breaking News.
- [Woman] Tonight, it
all comes down to this.
- So, let's just first define
what the news is or should be.
The news or the press
or the fourth estate,
this sort of sacred thing,
is meant to be a magnifying
glass on our society.
It's meant to look at the things
that are really important,
to make people stand accountable,
to highlight the issues that
you should be thinking about
when you're voting or going
about your day-to-day life.
It's meant to give you
important information
about things like, I
don't know, pandemics.
(upbeat music)
- Clearly Nickelodeon is
pushing a global warming agenda.
- In short, it's meant to
keep the people informed
and aware of what is
important in the world.
But as a news consumer myself
and as someone who wants to be informed
and to understand how the world works,
I find that the news less and less
and less actually helps me do that.
- It is not the newspaper-
- But now you're pedaling in dishonesties
- So I've been thinking about this
and I wanna share it with you.
I'm gonna give you three
reasons why I hate the news.
Number one, the news often tells you
what isn't actually
happening in the world.
There's this onion article
that just sums it up
so well .00003% of things
that happen actually matter.
Oftentimes we look at the
news and we see crazy things
that are happening around the world.
If there is a mass homicide,
that would be national
news tomorrow morning,
if there's a terrorist
attack around the world,
that will be national
news tomorrow morning.
If a prominent politician
says something really embarrassing,
that will be national
news tomorrow morning.
- What's the naughtiest
thing you ever did?
- I have to confess when me and my friends
sort of used to run through
the fields of wheat,
the farmers weren't
too pleased about that.
- What all these things
have in common is that
they don't happen very often,
they're super rare.
They don't teach us anything about
how the world actually works,
they teach us about how
the world doesn't work
and how sometimes it does,
the outliers, the aberrations.
My big problem with this is that someone
who reads the news every day
and uses it as their gateway
into the world will often walk away
with a completely delusional version
of how the world works.
They will assume that terrible
things happen more often
than they actually do.
Our view of the world is at stake here.
When the information available to us
is the stuff that doesn't
happen very often,
the stuff that's actually
an aberration from the norm.
We get a distorted view
of how the world works.
Number two, the news
has become way too fun.
- [Man] Meeting with
the pirate, no problem.
- [Announcer] Tonight,
president Donald Trump
fighting for a second term as
a deadly pandemic gets worse.
- This is not a legal proceeding.
- This is the congress of the united-
- This is an impeachment.
- My old colleague, Carlos
Maza has thought a lot
about how fun the news has become.
I called him up and we chatted about it.
How are you?
- I know good to see your face.
See for longest, as long as
you've had corporate news
in America is that we have a product
that is trying to meet two
very different objectives
or a suit, a very different incentive.
- What Carlos explained to
me that was really helpful
was that the news has
two opposing incentives.
The first incentive is what I
talked about at the beginning
of this video, which is
to inform the people,
to teach you what you should care about,
to give you a framework for
understanding the world,
for highlighting important information
the public should know,
but then there's this other incentive.
- The corporate media is
trying to sell you a product
and they sell your
product to make you think
you need as much of it as
humanly possible all the time.
(upbeat music)
So newscasts should be
maybe an hour every day
and then you're done
like, go do your thing.
You have this other incentive though,
while you have a corporate
media environment
that is like always breaking.
(logo squishing)
There's always a new thing
that you have to worry about.
So you have this basically
impossible impasse
of a product that you should
not really need that much,
that shows a specific function
being run by companies
that want you to need it all the time.
- I am not distracting.
- You've been doing it for
over a year and a half.
- I haven't been doing that.
- Well you have.
- What this does, is it
incentivize programming
that is optimized to appeal to our senses,
whether it's fear based sensationalism
or whether it's flashy graphics,
article titles that are
a little bit click baity.
The economic incentive
that is built into news
makes it really difficult
for news to honor
that first incentive.
- I call them a moron,
and then I modified
that word with a vulgar
Anglo-Saxons term that is
also intelligible in dutch.
- And instead, to prioritize entertainment
and false feelings of this is
important or this is scary.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] This is CNN breaking news.
- It seems like a really dangerous thing
to be so subject to economic forces.
Okay, my number three is
that the news tricks you
into feeling informed.
For a long time I read
the news every single day,
I would go on and read
multiple different outlets
and I would feel that day like check.
Okay, I believe that I'm
an informed smart person
and I've just sort of
confirmed that belief
because there's this sort
of like glorification
of the person who like
really up on the daily news.
What I've learned is that
that's actually not the case.
- Why don't people just check out
and that's a legitimate response,
like if the town prior in your
village constantly screaming,
10,000 horrific things at
you from other villages
that you don't live in,
after all you'd stop
really meaningfully listening to it
because your brain can not
sort out what catastrophe
is real and meaningful and
what you shouldn't respond to.
So you have this like kind
of ambient anxiety always
that makes it so that your
brain becomes numb to the drug.
You stop really caring about
what you should engage in.
- Spending a lot of time
chasing the new cycle
is a lot of mental energy.
It's a lot of mental energy
that could be applied
to understanding how the
world actually works,
consuming things that actually shed light
on important issues like,
policy or I don't know,
historical trends that maybe
are not as flashy and reactive,
but are way more indicative
on how the world works,
how things get done, how
change gets made in a society.
Instead because of this
entertainment incentive,
the news doesn't actually end
up being super informative.
You're not actually learning
a lot about anything
other than what happened that
day, who said what to whom
and why, and then how a
billion people reacted
to why that person said whom.
And it's like, it becomes a
giant gossip first almost.
- Binge watch like the
Rockford files, Netflix.
- Or modern love
- That's terrible.
Modern love makes me sick.
- How about person of interest?
- Ooh, I like that,
that's a good show.
- Can I say something now?
- Yes.
- No!
- It's built to appeal
more to our gossip impulse
than to our desire to
learn about the world.
The epidemy of this is the sort
of like pseudo debate format
that a lot of TV news takes apart.
- The five person talking head panel,
you have moderator who pretends
to be relatively neutral
and then four commentators
two from the left,
two from the right who
are arguing about whatever
the topic of the day is.
That format is a straight rip from ESPN.
Like those formats are a
carbon copy of the arguing
and almost like a reality
TV model that has been used
in sports media for a while.
- This is not journalism.
This looks like journalism
because it looks like there's
a robust debate going on.
- Stop it, you're abusing
power right now on air.
Stop filibustering her.
- But journalism is about evidence.
It's about going out
and gathering evidence
and scrutinizing it and
then putting it together
and presenting it to a reader.
In this sensationalized news segment,
no evidence is being
examined or scrutinized
or cross-examined.
- It serves no educational function,
regardless of what you
think about politics,
watching two people
argue is not informative
because it's too fast paced,
it triggers your tribal defenses,
you're not gonna be open-minded
and there's no time to examine evidence,
no matter how long that fight goes on for,
you are not gonna learn
anything meaningful from it.
All will happen is that
you will leave thinking,
"God, I really hate the other side."
And God by sight is so right.
It's the opposite of what
journalism should be doing.
- You don't leave a debate
like this anymore informed,
all you do is leave a debate like this
with like an understanding
that your side is right,
the other side is wrong
and like how awesome
that like the people who
represented your side
were like so hard on the opposing side,
which is a super awesome
impulse if you're like
in a football stadium watching
your favorite team play.
But when we're talking
about like real issues
and real policy, this sports
framework of commentary
and fighting is not very useful
because it tricks people into thinking
that they're informed, that they're like,
"oh, I get the issues now
'cause I watched that debate."
But instead all they were was entertained.
- I'm tired of having this
discussion over and over again.
- So those are my three reasons
for why I hate the news.
So let me just say one thing,
which is there is still amazing journalism
being done right now,
really important journalism
that is communicating important evidence,
about important ideas
that truly can inform you
about how the world works.
The incentives of this industry
make it harder and harder
for that journalism to happen.
But the journalists who are
out there collecting evidence,
reporting on really difficult things,
talking to lots of experts,
trying to piece together,
all of this information so that
they can inform the public.
Those are the people
who are doing this work
in spite of the entertainment,
corporate 24 hour news cycle
that has sort of taken
over what news should be.
And what I really believe
and I learned this
working at Vox, a place that
really focused on context
and explainer journalism,
there's a demand for it,
there will always be a
demand of voyeuristic demand
for seeing terrible things happen.
There will always be
demand for entertainment
and shouting matches, but
I believe that most people
want to understand,
they want to understand
why this certain policy will
work and the other one won't.
They want to understand the real debates,
the philosophical and political debates
that are happening in our system.
They wanna understand how our system works
or doesn't work.
And if only our news
industry could focus more
on that desire, that desire to understand,
instead of this facade of information
that is really just entertainment.
- The media is shoving
this down your throat.
- By the way, our ratings are great.
- Shouldn't they for a period
of time not go on the attack?
- They were fear-based.
- Hate in teleprompt.
- Can you give us an answer,
why were you attacking us.
- Don't be rude, you are fake dues.
- All right, well, that
was a little bit of a rant.
Just taking some deep breaths,
glad I got that out of my system.
If you want a place to put
your rants and thoughts
out into the world, choose Squarespace,
which is a one-stop
shop where you can build
an online presence as someone
who runs an internet business
and thinks about internet,
community, and marketing,
all this stuff,
Squarespace truly does have
an amazing set of tools
for developing a voice
and a presence on the internet
and doing so in a beautiful way.
They've got these templates
that are like really
nice looking and
well-designed, it's all easy
and drag and drop, it's not like code.
Like you go back and
you build your website.
Squarespace supports this channel
and I'm really grateful for that.
There's a link in my description,
if you click that link,
you get 10% off your first
purchase of anything,
whether it's a domain or hosting service
or whatever Squarespace offers 10% off.
Clicking that link helps
support this channel,
but it also can kickstart
your online presence
if that's something you're
thinking about doing,
you should check out Squarespace.
So thank you all for being
here and for listening
to my big rant about the news.
I am in the middle of
brainstorming, some really fun
wild big deep videos for 2021,
some international explainers
that I am working on
right now that I think
you're all gonna really like,
and they just take more
time to do journalism,
just takes more time.
I have to go and like read all this stuff,
talking to the experts,
reading all of like
the journals and the think
tank pieces and all this stuff,
putting it together that just takes time.
But quality journalism is an
important thing, so anyway
have a great day I'll talk to you later.
- SpongeBob what are you doing?
- Just rolling another tire on the fire
by global warming Mr Graham.
(upbeat music)